[Música]
foto ap ó primeiramente pessoal queria
desejar boa tarde de você pra vocês e
agradecer imensamente o convite da
aldeia participar desse projeto e
agradeceu a presença de vocês
e também gostaria de um boa tarde bem
caloroso aqui pra todo mundo ficar
sintonizado na mesma freqüência vamos lá
boa tarde aí sim vamos lá então o ted um
momento de inspiração pessoas um momento
onde eu já havia algumas apresentações
me inspirei muito então estou até um
pouco nervoso aqui falando com vocês mas
creio que vai ser de algo muito positivo
e espera inspirar vocês pelo menos o
mínimo que seja
quero começar o primeiro falando sobre o
alinha da palestra é desse nosso
bate-papo que vai ser o resgate
então o foco no resgate eu como na área
da gastronomia o meu resgate vem através
do resgate de técnicas de culinária
só que esse resgate de técnicas
culinárias me levou um resgate cultural
da onde a gente vive dona edith mora e
esse resgate me fez olhar para trás e
olhar para dentro e me tornar uma pessoa
melhor
então tive vários tombos e vários
presentes da vida que me fizeram
melhorar é ter um desempenho melhor com
o profissional tem um desempenho melhor
como pessoa como pai com o companheiro
eu quero compartilhar um pouco disso
nesse leve cronograma na minha nova
aventura gastronomia
eu tenho 28 anos trabalha com
gastronomia 10 e passei por vários
vários formatos de restaurantes aqui em
curitiba em são paulo é trabalhar com
questões cozinha clássica italiana
francesa trabalha em restaurante
tailandês
viajei pra praia para trabalhar numa
linha de formato mais descontraída
segundo pf servido um lanche é voltei
para curitiba e tive a oportunidade de
trabalhar no restaurante japonês
me fez pesquisar muito e mergulhar muito
na cultura ambiental e essa essa imersão
uma olhada com os é que os
acontecimentos da vida me transformou
muito como pessoa sendo a pessoa que eu
sou hoje
e agora a gente volta para 2009 quando
entrei na cozinha e eu era um jovem
perdido na vida tinha largado a idéia de
que eu queria fazer quartel não sei
porque o pneu quartel não é seu fui lá e
fui fazer inscrição no quartel cheguei
lá afirmando que estou fazendo aqui você
que não é pra mim é vida que eu quero a
minha mãe falou que precisa estudar
fazer alguma coisa na vida e eu em si eu
resolvi entrar na gastronomia por pura
sorte e eu levo isso do meu pai da minha
mãe que eles sempre falavam que você tem
que honrar a profissão que você escolheu
e eu levei isso comigo leves até hoje e
desde o início da gastronomia e sempre
foi uma pessoa muito questionador era
uma pessoa muito inquieta queremos saber
sempre o porquê das coisas querendo ser
sempre melhor número que os outros mas
sempre melhor e sempre ter o melhor
aproveitamento da profissão que eu tava
estava tendo do ofício que tinha
escolhido a minha vida e trabalhei horas
e horas netinha uma média de trabalho aí
quando não estava na faculdade de 10 a
14 horas por dia de trabalho e aquilo
não me fazia mal naquela época porque eu
não tinha um esse meu lado mais humano
que eu tenho hoje
antigamente só focava na profissão e ser
melhor com um profissional e qualquer é
aquela frase nem os fins justificam os
meios
eu abdiquei do meu lado pessoal eu
comecei a focar na gastronomia 100% da
minha vida perdi relacionamentos não só
de namoradas mas é como os familiares
com meus amigos e isso impactou muito
mas nesses quatro anos além de 2009 e
focado muito na alta gastronomia nota
desempenho eu realmente tive 11 avanço
legal e um sucesso que pra mim era o que
bastava em 2003 eu ganhei um prêmio de
chef revelação pela gazeta do povo
fazendo o menu que enaltecia a culinária
local com produtos locais aqui do nosso
bioma da mata atlântica produtos de
morrer os produtos do nosso interior do
paraná e aquilo lá
com isso me trouxe
depressão porque eu sempre ia ser melhor
que aquela pressão foi me consumindo me
consumindo comecei com 22 anos de idade
de crise de ansiedade
comecei te falta de noção de espaço no
meio da cozinha e perder ficar ponto e
eu comecei a me questionar sobre estilo
de vida que eu levava aquilo me fazia
bem
literalmente no final de 2014
após passar alguns estágios em são paulo
nos restaurantes renomados onde foi
introduzido no mundo da fermentação que
essa é uma coisa muito importante a
falar daqui a pouquinho sobre a
fermentação aliada muito o resgate das
técnicas e eu vivi aquela pressão e
aquilo foi me consumindo e chegou um
momento que eu literalmente fazei da
alta gastronomia e foi morar na praia
morena praia eu conheci pessoas que
tinham um outro ritmo na praia vida é
outra é outro esquema na praia é muito
mais devagar as pessoas são muito mais
calmas
então comecei a pensar poxa aqui eu
tenho tempo de de pensar em mim eu tenho
tempo de qualidade com cios e
introspectivo e aquele mesmo
questionamento que eu sempre fazia com
os meus chefes com os colegas de
trabalho para ser melhor eu fazia só que
agora para mim como eu poderia ser uma
pessoa melhor
como poderia transformar o ambiente que
eu trabalho num ambiente melhor para que
os outros não passassem pelo que eu
passei eu não sofri nenhuma cobrança dos
meus chefes sofria muitas mas não vem ao
caso
mas a maior cobrança que eu sofria era
minha e aquilo me fez mal e quando
obtivesse é essa imersão na praia com as
outras pessoas com outro estilo de vida
eu comecei realmente a me questionar mas
não era ainda um questionamento muito
forte muito profundo eu porque eu ainda
queria ser alta performance alto
desempenho e realmente não estava muito
ligado aos meus familiares
só que eu não entendia e em 2014 para
2015 trabalhei um monte e trabalhava em
uma média de 300 horas por mês nos meses
do verão é e aquilo era minha vida e
tudo mais eu recebi a oportunidade de
voltar para curitiba para trabalhar no
nos melhores restaurantes que hoje eu
considero que aqui em curitiba
[Música]
e quando eu estava literalmente com a
carta de demissão na mão sabendo que eu
ia voltar para aquela vida da sua
gastronomia
eu comecei a sentir uma necessidade de
demi agitassem fui andar de skate
no dia que eu peguei a minha carta de
demissão eu quebrei meu pé fiquei quatro
meses de cama sem poder andar e
dependendo da queda as pessoas na rua me
dediquei quando buscava alta performance
então deixei de lado minha família nessa
época mas quando quebrei meu pé quem
suportou que me deu apoio foi a minha
família
então é isso me foi um primeiro
aprendizado na minha vida então tipo
poxa eu abdiquei que estava me segurando
é e agora aqui quem está quem está aqui
comigo é o que está acontecendo com o
que era há um objetivo qual é o sentido
real da minha vida
e nesse meio tempo minha namorada
engravidou
aqui na frente e pra mim foi um baque
assim mas foi muito bom porque realmente
me fez dar o outro está lutando deveria
ser uma pessoa melhor porque agora não
era só pra mim era uma outra vida que
depende de mim
o nosso filho se espelha na gente então
antes de eu ser um bom pai precisava ser
uma boa pessoa e nesse meio tempo não
conseguir fazer fisioterapia porque a
vida é muito corrida tinha acabado de
sair da cirurgia precisava fazer
dinheiro pra agora tentar sustentar uma
família com o emprego de cozinheiro que
hoje tem uma visibilidade boa mas ainda
é o emprego que sofre muito preconceito
é o emprego que os salários são
ridículos então tinha que fazer
acontecer o que o que a vida me
mostrasse eu tinha que fazer acontecer
sendo cozinheiro e aqui em curitiba
estava frustrado com o jeito que era
feita a gestão da dos restaurantes e
gestão da da gastronomia e voltei praia
do rosa
passei o verão lá pra conseguir fazer
conseguiu juntar dinheiro e de novo com
a pressão eu voltei a ter os padrões
comportamentais que eu tinha buscando o
desempenho e depois de trabalhar de novo
300 horas com 11 de dezembro no primeiro
dia de folga e consequente que eu era
estava fazendo
o vasco sair correndo e mergulha de
ponta uma piscina e essa piscina tinha
um aviso de um metro e meio de que a
piscina tinha um metro de profundidade
aí eu quase quebrou a cabeça eu
literalmente fiquei com os quase 12
centímetros de corte aberto na minha
cabeça e quando cheguei no hospital o
médico falou que por sorte não tinha
ficado tetraplégico
então em menos de um ano a vida me deu
dois sinais de que eu precisava mudar e
e o principal sinal é que agora era que
a minha consequência afetava não somente
a mim mas uma futura família que estava
se criando então passou alguns meses
nasceu bento
a gente volta pra eu volto para curitiba
e assumo a essa questão do restaurante
japonês foi a primeira menção no
restaurante japonês em la de novo eu
tive essa questão do do retorno aos
produtos fermentados que eu tinha lá em
2014 e comecei a estudar estudar e
estudar muito a questão da fermentação a
fermentação e me levou a comprar um
livro chamado antes da fermentação eu
comecei a estudar estudar aquilo e
comecei a reparar que as os produtos
fermentados eram iguais o que meu pai
não vou fazer quando era moleque
então nada na vida por acaso então toda
a gente acha que a gente toma nosso
destino por conta própria mas realmente
não é isso que acontece
as nossas decisões reflitam muito no que
a gente tem hoje
e sem a gente saber muda todo o nosso
futuro de uma forma positiva então uma
coisa que eu espero que eu gosto de
lembrar é que não importa o quão difícil
está sendo nosso momento hoje isso é
ensinamento para depois parece meio
clichê mas realmente eu vivi isso é em
com toda essa má notícia de ser pai de
ser tocar a responsabilidade de tocar
uma família o meu primeiro emprego de
chefe com 25 anos de idade tocando uma
equipe com oito pessoas a pessoa mais
velha da equipe tinha 22 anos
é eu tive que aplicar todo esse
conhecimento que eu vinha tendo durante
os sonhos da minha vida em questão de
gestão em questão de sabor porque eu
precisava inovar porque era contra o
sistema de gestão
e era rolava nas cozinhas e eu não
acreditava na cozinha do velho mundo
europa naquela cozinha européia que eu
acho muito limitada
é então com menos de seis meses com a
equipe fechada com esse novo método de
gestão com um psicológico positiva
enaltecendo as qualidades do da equipe
das pessoas e com isso as pessoas
aumentando o desempenho delas uma forma
muito leve muito natural e
automaticamente elas percebendo que o
respeito que eu tinha por elas o
respeito que tinha pêlos insumos
respeito que eu tinha pelas adversidades
que aconteciam elas começaram a aplicar
e quando a pessoa tem respeito o
ingrediente ela começa a desperdiçar
menos e com esse desperdício menor com
essa o aumento no desempenho a gente
conseguiu reduzir 18% de custo do
restaurante é resultando numa economia
de seis meses aí um valor
aproximadamente 150 mil reais
então trazendo à tona e confirmando que
a esse novo método de gestão aliada a
essa nova cozinha moderna com foco no
resgate cultural de técnicas
é uma coisa nova que a gente pode pôr em
prática mas na nossa família cresceu a
gente precisava mudar a gente voltou
praia do rosa
a gente enfrentou alguns problemas a
gente cresceu muito pessoalmente eu
plantei fiz uma plantação de milho
eu fiz trabalhei com resgate em
solo fazendo compostagem para plantar
ervas de casa construir um galinheiro
com meu pai então tudo aquilo que eu
vivi na infância pode replicar agora
para nossa família e isso me mudou
demais assim e infelizmente devido à má
gestão de dos diretores de uma empresa
que a gente estava a gente fez um
investimento muito alto pra praia do
rosa acabou não pagando a gente teve que
voltar porque não fazia mais sentido
aquele empreendimento de de energia numa
coisa perdida e sem nada do que perder
um pouco relutante porque eu não curtia
muito a questão da nossa mídia hoje
porque muita parte do da mídia que a
gente tenha acesso tem foco no
sensacionalismo e mas eu tinha uma outra
cabeça e resolvi me inscrever numa chefe
quando escrevi numa chefe
eu conseguia aplicar de uma forma muito
leve a minha questão da psicologia
positiva do pensamento elevado de todas
as técnicas de todos os estudos que eu
tive durante esses anos de profissão e
deu no que deu conseguir dar um tem um
desempenho bacana no programa conseguir
ter visibilidade e essa visibilidade eu
estou usando e comecei a usar ela com
foco para realmente dá poder de palavra
poder de diálogo nessa linha da
gastronomia porque não é muito muito
enaltecida hoje ainda há gente ainda
vivem alguns restaurantes como o regime
militar
então isso me preocupava e hoje eu tenho
voz para mudar isso
então além de trabalhar com o resgate de
técnicas poder fazer um projeto e eu
consiga enaltecer dois focos de um
projeto que é que é a questão que foi
agora da psicologia positiva que é a
outra questão numa outra ponta que
incomoda muitas pessoas que são os
sabores provocativos o amargo azedo o
defumado então tinha voz pra fazer isso
e com isso é hoje viaja o brasil fazendo
algumas consultorias fazendo eventos
estou abrindo um restaurante no próximo
mês e tudo isso eu só consegui depois eu
percebi que o foco da da minha visão
começou a se desenvolver quando comecei
a olhar para trás quando comecei a fazer
o resgate de técnicas gastronômicas o
resgate cultural
tudo isso caminha junto quando a gente
resgata a gente olha para trás a gente
consegue olhar pra gente e ver o que
realmente importa na nossa vida
para resumir um pouco porque a gente
pode falar da questão de resgate assim a
gente vai muito além e o ponto que eu
quero trazer aqui pra gente focando no
resgate cultural que eu tive na cozinha
me transformou com uma pessoa melhor
automaticamente me transformando um pai
melhor e expunha exponencialmente me
tornando um líder e não um chefe então
me evoluir profissionalmente de um jeito
que não evoluir se não tivesse se
estamos na vida eo resgate de de
técnicas que gosta de trabalhar
é focado na nas minhas vivências então
quando eu era criança eu tinha meu pai
que faz as conservas meu avô que fazia
vinho
meu tio avô que abate o próprio animal
para fazer a linguiça para fazer os
produtos que eram consumidos meu tio
fazer churrasco de seis sete horas que a
gente almoçar com fogo de chão eu
comecei a juntar se aos pedaços e
comecei a aplicar nesse nesse novo
projeto que eu tô fazendo a minha vida
que é basicamente utilizar a filosofia
oriental do respeito que eles têm com a
base que a gente tem no nosso país
eu sou de descendência polonesa então a
fermentação tão impregnado em mim essa
linha está impregnado em mim mas eu sou
brasileiro então eu quero enaltecer a
gastronomia brasileira e quando a gente
fala em resgate a gente fala em índio
a gente fala eu trabalho trabalho e
trabalho com foco na culinária oriental
com base na culinária indígena estava
conversando agora há pouco
existem traços genéticos que comprovam
que os índios têm descendência orientais
então nada por acaso de novo na nossa
vida e o que eu quero dizer agora aqui
pra vocês
o resgate ele não vem só na cultura já
tem muita gente esse resgate da gente a
gente começa realmente mudar então
aquela frase que a gente é o que a gente
come é realmente verdadeira e eu tenho
que todo mundo aqui tem um pensamento
questionador e de querer crescer e se
desenvolver porque senão nem estava aqui
que eu quero deixar para vocês essa
gente é o que a gente come o que vocês
estão fazendo para se alimentar bem o
quanto que vocês se importam para ter
uma alimentação saudável e se você se
importa o que estão fazendo para mudar
porque aqui a gente tem que acabar com o
desmatamento gente tem que acabar com a
exploração indígena a gente que não
enaltecer o nosso país porque a gente é
muito rico a gente só precisa ter o
suporte das pessoas que estão aqui com a
gente então é isso que eu quero trazer
para vocês quero agradecer esse resgate
cultural é o tema da palestra é
literalmente esse resgate cultural como
um bom posicionamento atual
então a gente olhar para trás para a
gente desenvolver um futuro melhor com
nosso país
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]